drove through baton rouge twice but i've  like hung out in new orleans a couple of  times but like culturally it feels like  musically different it's just a whole  different world right yeah new orleans  they they like the cities we call them  the city  they don't they don't the music is  really right all the way very different  they don't they don't  it's like it's louisiana then it's new  orleans um so it's like its own world  world you know we any we so cool with  them but they just so different you guys  i feel like i feel like baton rouge in  like like texas has really always kind  of had more kind of more on the same  page new orleans then a whole nother  like they're in a whole other world than  this